yes my name is master Cher I don't hate
it
my name is Pierre welcome back to
killing you know it's - what is what's
going on here pity did you do that did
you do this I got experience even I have
a bigger penis than that
now I must share god damn that guy
scared me in the last episode
this is cover-up no cover-up there we go
much better hey this [ __ ] smug ass
face I just want to [ __ ] on it that's
very pretty
I'll watch him before you go alright let
make sure he doesn't tell apart stop
making me spin alright share mode
activate OOP nice share mode thank you
pity you so much all right we got what
we came for the bedroom key what are you
doing this year you're not supposed to
be on tables I know I'm just Academies
Boris like we saw him a lot in the
beginning area some two times but I'm
missing I have a hundred and thirty
thousand that I want to spend I don't
know why I just want my tall tears give
me my child I mean I have my answer I
want to spend my daughter I love
shopping I shop every day every day
every day I'm shopping look at this 360
yeah yeah that's 720 business
god dammit why didn't you tell me stop
wasting my lunch and I don't trust you
get the [ __ ] outta me all right
you're actually coming with me how about
that how about that ah you see what I do
to people do you like here the people
who harass me [ __ ] slam your [ __ ] in
their ceiling you like this [ __ ] you
like this [ __ ]
alright let's go in here this is no I
don't want to go in here we're looking
for the bedroom
I suppose nope
stop hey that could be you know this is
a bedroom but I'm pretty sure it's not
what I'm looking for so we're just going
to go walk on the car
I got a feeling we already been here
holiday fare chef Jennifer it's frickin
huge
all right where's the bedroom dad and me
I don't think it's very here either
I think it's in here or maybe here what
is this no that's not how I would came
from all right then I'm just gonna check
my head and jump grab my head and jump
or tell my head and John tell my head
and jump make up my head and jump and
help my head and down tilt my head and
jump come on what am I supposed to go
tell me game give me a sign give me
anything I hate that [ __ ] some maybe
it's here where the I don't trust you
let's see if we can get it triple bill
[ __ ] assignment one kill
I've actually decapitated a little bit
all right what do we have here ah it's
pretty good I don't trust you not you
either
all right hey LSPD
you know what I'm proud of you you made
it this far I'm pretty sure this is the
last episode I just want to say all
liberals I hope you enjoyed as an epic
series look at me I'm just relating and
[ __ ] that's not [ __ ] a cyan what are
you talking about I'm gonna end this
with a breakdance there we go
All Right see you later Connor yes
yes don't want to hit my head on that
thing all right but not um no I never
know all right just go buddy I don't
trust this [ __ ] and I don't trust any
one of you [ __ ] I hate you and I hate
all of you
this is pretty cold eh not gonna lie all
right well I don't
[Music]
I ain't got [ __ ] I don't chest here [ __ ]
am I supposed to go I come on
[Music]
why am I supposed to go if they're all
locked then I can bat on Tessa painting
okay so we need to find key oh just go
here hey doggy
hi Perry higher dad I love your show
lek I'm tripping out whoa whoa whoa I'm
a dog all right
buckets just annoying dog that's what
you are
Hey look at this oh sorry dog
sorry doc I just can't take your dog
hole know what they're called make
suspecting something bad
I command it I didn't know the dogs
could climb ladders that's awesome all
right and there's just sealing in the
roof [ __ ] just said all right whoo
secret engines I get the feeling I've
been here before though okay let's check
this room no of course it's long I have
a [ __ ] room
god damn it that's good Oh Oh what the
hell do you have to make love in front
of me uh I don't have anything against
gay people but holy [ __ ] this takes it
to the new level whatta hell is good
look at this I don't want to pee I don't
like it
I'll share more down there share more
activate Oh nicely done sir all right
that was pointless love the pointed
stuff
alright let's go in here it's me
no I said dirty pot I'm here to kill you
that's it where's this man it's my penis
it's been said who are you talking to
why do you come here to stab you
[ __ ] because of Vincent's
victims now
[Music]
you can use the dagger to killed your
hand and take your revenge or definitely
even mine it out you know what your
highness there's a lot of stuff I want
to do with you if you know what I mean
you know Janice so I might think you're
old and disgusting but you know if you
know what I mean
but others might like it if you know
what I mean some people might think it's
weird out would buy a ghost with floods
around in the air but some might like it
if you know what I mean
piggy I'm talking about pinging alright
I guess we're gonna kill him but
ha yes I made you into a woman that's
with [ __ ] dead because you have a
vagina yes it makes sense
all right did we make it did we make it
brush
[Music]
I have a huge ton by the way I don't
know
could like drink from it
[Music]
mmm-hmm oh okay so tasty
all right let's discuss thing I'm do
apologize all right
oh we made it thank heaven cows hey
happy hey I'm sure you made it out alive
I'm a cow you should be called I want to
say mocked in but here you go Ahead's
potatoes you will not have a name
actually here you have some more
potatoes just cause she looks so happy
you just take this from the head that's
what she said
he said in fact that was gay all right
anyway hope you know it is let's play
I'm just gonna whip my ass away what
what like if he says you know there's
let's play subscribe to come abroad
today and I'll see you next time Misha
let's play there's an excellent cutting
story I thoroughly enjoyed it I like
when they're a bit longer but I do like
enjoy my weird customers as well I don't
know what else to say
Devin nearly David advanced mapping and
voices and Chris Gensler and Elias
Midland three and oh he made the boys
you're my own I will never forget boy
awesome Oh in the game but to me I get
there oh look at that da you are you too
much I didn't do it
baby [ __ ] I don't know why but thanks
anyway there comes a bro
[Music]
see this see this front flip but there
you're doing on your [ __ ]